Equifax the company whose name sounds
like a theatrical production in which
Daniel Radcliffe plays a horse that
a fax machine now Equifax is one
of the big three credit reporting
agencies the companies who keep
financial data on all of us so that
people like lenders and landlords can
decide whether or not we are trustworthy
so Equifax controls some of our most
sensitive information and about a month
ago we learned this breaking news from
the credit monitoring company Equifax
cyber thieves making off with private
information of a hundred forty three
million Americans nearly half the u.s.
population it's actually worse it's now
a hundred and forty five million
Americans and I've got good news and bad
news here the good news is that by
private information they don't mean your
Google search history so nobody yet
knows about the time you searched for
Wario porn parenthesis real or world's
richest dogs looking for assistance or
can loneliness caused the farts but the
bad news is the information they got
could well be all this it's your name
social security number birth date
driver's license and addresses where you
lived
information that is mostly permanent
unless you're in federal witness
protection
Wow okay so that does sound bad but here
is a simple solution just move a hundred
and forty five million people into the
witness protection program
that means Jonesy's you are the
Thompsons thompson's you're the
campbells at Campbell's or the Mendozas
Mendozas you're the Joneses wait wait
hold on Joneses you shouldn't be there I
made you the Thompsons no thompson's I
made you the Campbell's Campbell's
you're the Mendozas Mendozas why are you
that you should be living in the Joneses
house in Phoenix oh no I shouldn't said
Phoenix oh god the judges are dead the
judge forget the whole plan I was just
trying to help I'm sorry for trying
and I know there might be some younger
people watching this thing will hold who
cares we're the first generation to
routinely send pictures our junk to each
other over the Internet
why should we give a about someone
seeing our social security numbers but
you should know criminals can do a lot
more with that number than they can with
a picture of your dick this information
is gonna be sold left and right on the
black market people are going to be able
to open up credit cards for the rest of
your life once they have that
information they can go out and purchase
a home in your name they can open bank
accounts take car loans someone who has
your social security number could
actually take a job they could file
taxes and even claim your kids as
dependents and be gone with your refund
before you ever actually file a tax
return no no no the tax benefit is the
whole point of having children without
that all you're left with is your actual
children but you know the point here is
it's a huge problem and in any other era
this would have been the biggest news
story for a month but but now that every
day's headline is simply the words
everything batshit bananas again today
it slipped under the radar but it is
worth asking how the hell did this
happen because the short answer is the
people in charge have done literally
everything wrong and let's start with
just just the way that Equifax told us
about the hack in early September their
then CEO Rick Smith a man with a face
and name so bland he may as well be
called human person or Frasier rerun he
issued a taped apology but his remarks
seemed a little less than heartfelt on
July 29th of this year we discovered
that attackers had gained unauthorized
access to certain Equifax data files
this is clearly a disappointing event
and one that strikes at the heart of who
we are and what we do Rick Smith is so
alarmingly mechanical you probably have
to put him in rice every time he gets
wet
now notably he mentioned there that
Equifax learned about the breach on July
29th but even more notably that video
was uploaded in September which is and
this is true after July so Equifax knew
about the breach for nearly six weeks
before telling the public and they
claimed that they need at that time
because the investigation was complex
and time-consuming although that's not
all that happened in that time span
three Equifax executives sold nearly two
million dollars in company's stock days
after the data breach was discovered Wow
selling stock before the public knows
there's a problem is one of those things
that look suspicious whether or not
you're actually doing something wrong
it's like walking into a petting zoo
with a bib on what exactly are you
planning on messily devouring in there
and Equifax defended that saying none of
the executives in question including
their chief financial officer knew about
the data breach which raises another
question how is that even possible
did they just ignore emails with the
subject lines breach
following up on breach where the
are you breach breach breach and just
spoke to you in person about breach and
you just stared blankly at me and then
said I'm gonna order from that salad
place and if you are getting frustrated
already with this kind of incompetence
you're gonna need to pace yourself
because this story gets a lot worse
apparently there were multiple points
where this hack could have been
prevented and one of them is incredible
because Equifax were alerted by Homeland
Security back in March
that they needed to fix a critical
vulnerability in their software but as
lawmakers discovered at a recent hearing
that's not what happened there was one
person apparently who forgot to tell
somebody that they had a piece of
software that needed to be patched it is
not ideal for the company guarding such
valuable information leaves something
that important down to one person it's
not finding out that Chase Bank has a
big red button labeled lose everyone's
money and the only thing stopping anyone
from pushing it is Frank and I love
Frank
I love the guy but what if he has to pee
I don't want to tell you that this is an
anomaly but Equifax has had multiple
headline-grabbing breaches over the
years and that is not even counting
smaller incidents like this I checked my
credit report the other day online with
Equifax that was it and next thing I
know I have 300 pieces of mail sittin in
my mailbox every single one of these is
addressed to her but they're not hers
instead she got other people's credit
reports now names Social Security
numbers dates of birth current and
previous addresses bank and loan account
numbers all stacked up on a kitchen
table in Biddeford that's not great is
it and it really should have set off red
flags at Equifax when hundreds of
different credit reports were being
mailed to the same address what exactly
did you think had happened there that
every single Fraggle
checks their credit at once down at
Fraggle Rock down at Fraggle Rock not
very nice
and I know that other companies have had
breaches but non remotely as damaging as
this new Equifax one because remember
this isn't Target
exposing customers credit cards this is
compromising Social Security numbers the
things that thieves could use to open
new credit cards in your name and if
your information was stolen which
remember is about a 50/50 chance it
could haunt you forever you don't change
your birth date you don't change your
social security number those who have
been jeopardized by this hack will have
to protect themselves for years until
they're dead
it's true and just think about that
there is only one other thing that you
have to constantly protect yourself from
until you're dead and that's
death
and you would hope that Equifax would do
a decent job of mitigating the damage
after all they did have nearly six weeks
to work on a response but instead their
fuck-ups continued for instance they
created a website for concerned
consumers to go to but then this
happened
but site that Equifax started is called
Equifax security 2017 but a developer
named Nick Sweeting wanted to show how
easy it is to create a similar fake site
so he did he called it security Equifax
2017 exactly someone created a fake site
and if you thinking well who would be
dumb enough to fall for that
Equifax that's who because they tweeted
links to that fake site at least eight
times despite the fact that site had a
couple of tiny clues that it might be
fake from the headline reading why did
Equifax use a domain that so easily
impersonated by phishing sites to the
fact that when you clicked on their
frequently asked questions this happened
[Music]
[Applause]
well-played pranksters you have my
respect but look don't worry
Equifax says that they are tightening up
their operation and to see how well that
they've done on that you you can just go
to Equifax fraud prevention com not
because it's their site but because it's
our site we bought it two days ago and
if you go there you'll find the message
how are we still able to do this why
haven't you learned anything but wait
wait because there is even more because
Equifax also offered consumers a year of
free credit monitoring but when people
try to sign up for the service they
noted something guess what
you were locked into Equifax Terms of
Service when you sign up for it which
means that you can't sue the company
you've got to resolve any disputes in
forced arbitration exactly you'd be
giving up your right to sue so legally
your best recourse at that point will be
shaking your fist of the heavens whilst
shouting Equifax now they've since
rescinded that clause although many
frustrated people are now signing up for
third-party credit monitoring services
like LifeLock who've been advertising
everywhere and they've seen a real surge
in business in the wake of this breach
although if you are considering LifeLock
because you are mad at Equifax there is
something you're going to need to know
according to filings with the SEC
lifelong purchases credit monitoring
services from Equifax and that means
someone buys credit monitoring through
life log LifeLock turns around and
passes some of that revenue directly
along to Equifax is that right mr. Smith
that is correct
if so some some of the money that you
pay to LifeLock goes right back to
Equifax which could only be more
infuriating if you then found out that
the rest of it goes to Toys for Tots a
charity that purchases sex toys for
grown men named
taught by your own sex toys Todd we
can't carry you on this one I'm not
equifax connections aside LifeLock has
had repeated issues itself including
settlements with the FTC and a truly
disastrous ad campaign a few years back
I'm Todd Davis and I'm here to prove
just how safe your identity can be with
LifeLock that's my real social security
number yep like flocks then CEO Todd
Davies actually put his real social
security number four five seven five
five five four six two on a truck and
billboards for a time it was impossible
to escape his social security number
four five seven five five five four six
two and that was a very cocky move and
one that resulted in him having his
identity stolen 13 times for the people
who took it was I didn't steal his
identity I literally cockatoo got it off
the back of a truck so to put it mildly
LifeLock may not be your best solution
to the Equifax crisis which brings us to
the question what is well consumer
advocates told us that the one big step
everyone should take is to go to all
three large credit reporting companies
that's Equifax Experian and TransUnion
and freeze your credit that way no one
can access it including you until you
unfreeze it now the companies also offer
their own credit protection products
with names like trusted ID or credit
lock plus but they are often more
expensive and offer fewer consumer
protection so if you need a way to
remember this locks are something you
don't want think of Justin Bieber's
dreadlocks a terrible decision to be
avoided whereas freezes are great think
of this tiny penguin losing its frogs in
mind
[Music]
see
so to recap locks oof freezes now now
here is the thing here's the thing on
this freezing and unfreezing your credit
can cost money which will go back to
these companies because seemingly they
just can't lose on this and if
you need any more proof of that on the
very same day the Congress was yelling
at Equifax his former CEO it emerged
that the company had just been awarded a
seven million dollar contract by the IRS
to prevent fraud which led one senator
to make a pretty brutal comparison you
realize too many Americans right now
that looks like we're giving Lindsay
Lohan the keys to the minibar
[Applause]
that was the pause of a man thinking do
I let that pass do I correct him on how
to pronounce Lohan or do I double down
and pronounce her name
lingonberry la holy baloney and you
should know you should know that IRS
deal has been suspended not canceled by
the way just suspended and that might
make you angry but the problem is that
anger won't have much impact on Equifax
because they make most of their money
selling our data to businesses like
banks so in their eyes we're not the
consumer with a product - think of it in
terms of KFC
we're not the guy buying the ten peace
buckets with the chickens so for
the time being businesses are the only
ones who can exert influence here and as
one colorfully dressed expert pointed
out that's not gonna happen anytime soon
I haven't heard any big company came out
come out yet and say we're not gonna use
Equifax anymore for their credit scores
point so far everybody's been quiet I
don't know what they're waiting to hear
this is outrageous they should be done
but I bet you because it's America
they'll be okay here's the truth that
angry business casual form animal on fox
business is talking sense and that
sentence alone shows just how bad things
are so in the long term they should
clearly be major reform to this industry
and how its regulated but that is going
to take time so until then you need to
freeze your credit reports with all
three of these companies and only
unfreeze them when you need to apply for
credit because the freezer option can be
hard to find on their sites if you go to
our Twitter feed we will give you the
exact links to do that and when you do
they will give you a PIN number that you
need to unfreeze it so do not lose that
number or the very least make it
something memorable I don't know like 4
5 7 5 5 5 4 6 2 but not that to the
course that's taught Davis's Social
Security number